almost every single person who's told me
they like the way I sounded but that
they didn't like the way I look I think
you're beautiful it's such an honor to
be here I'm among this incredible cast
so many people have been obviously
talking about your fashion but even more
so I think everyone is talking about
your extreme talent in this role and as
an actress what does this mean to you to
hear critics and fans across the world
say that you're a revelation in this
role I'm just extremely humbled and
grateful Bradley is an a visionary human
being he has such an eye for creating an
atmosphere of liberation and talent and
he he believed in me you know a hundred
people can be in a room in 99 don't
believe in you and just one person
believes in you and it can change
everything
and he believed in me and I am I'm so
grateful to him for that he he his
performance in this film is is out of
this world and I loved singing with him
as well his voice is beautiful we could
love Bradley more you know now he told
me tonight that the dog in the film was
his actual dog I didn't know that did
you ever get to puppy sit on set oh yes
we were always playing with Charlie yes
I think Dorinda told us that maybe your
mom is gonna be a real housewife in New
York have you heard anything about that
I have not heard about that yeah yes I
am yes I am but I have not heard about
that animal and I will have to speak
with my mother now at TIFF you had the
Vail moment and I thought is there any
possibility you can top this and tonight
Jevon she a train a cape tell me what
went into this love uh you know I I just
had a vision for silver lace and Javan
she did a beautiful job they were so
wonderful and you know Alex and Anna who
made the dress I'm just so grateful to
them
[Music]